here's what would happen if we killed  all the mosquitoes  luckily millions of people wouldn't get  sick and die each year  you could enjoy being outside in summer  without any fear of being bitten and  animals would be much safer as well  that's right not many bad things would  happen if we got rid of all the  mosquitoes sure some birds bats and  frogs eat quite a lot of mosquitoes but  they're not a hugely significant part of  other creatures diets  there are some theories that mosquitoes  may help protect the amazon rainforest  that's because they're so deadly and  annoying to the people trying to cut  down the rainforest that at times the  bugs actually prevent them from doing so  keep in mind there are thousands of  different species of mosquitoes and only  six percent of them bite us and spread  disease so would killing them off be the  right thing to do  what do you think